okay can we move on let's be serious
guys this is a news show
this is a new show bro playground news
at night yeah migrant news at night okay
I just want to say that there's been a
lot of video that's come back from uh me
trying to look cool as an adult at the
after party
okay yeah there's been a lot of video
that's been posted and not only did
Roddy Rich perform but Kodak Black also
performed yeah both performed multiple
songs there's to this day no video of me
even lip syncing the n-word wow
goat go do you know lyrics to either one
of their songs I mean I'm sure that word
pops up every once in a while but like I
you know you can't only sing along to
that word that's true but there is
that's very true I guess there is a
video that I posted where I look so
[__] dumb it's unbelievable and it's
when when
Kodak is rapping super Gremlin right
like right at me looking at me rapping
super Gremlin and I actually know the
words to Supergirl it's like one of my
favorite songs really yeah we can play
right now you don't want to play right
now oh no we can't because we're gonna
get it we can't but we can do acapella
though
I'm not one of those
I'm not one of those I need the words to
know the words well yeah that means you
don't know the words yeah you're a hater
no I'm just saying you're a hater that's
what that's what it is yeah if you just
say the word slightly after you just
heard them then that's not knowing it
nah it sounds like y'all are jealous you
didn't get to rap a Kodak well we could
be superstar
okay go ahead and I just went like this
but that's what you do when you don't
want to get caught saying some wild [__]
he was trying to set me up well we could
be Superstars we'd be rather wrecking
cars no that was it
what's the next one
that's that game that you just like you
get a couple yeah bars in and then you
gotta that's open let me see it no but
then you're gonna leave it to get me get
some give them a couple lines they're
gonna look at the lyrics
okay memorizing lyrics okay say you my
Imma Be Your killer
nobody gonna play with you when I'm with
you I don't like the first uh one at all
that's not it's too many m words in that
one but
lyrics perfectly when it's playing and
I'm there
wow
wow what a conspiracy
holy [__] wow
should we make an ancient [__]
history Show on Netflix I don't know all
the words to Kodak Black okay guys you
[__] did it [__] you miles you've
made the place
[__] you well
you're cool
okay do you know the [__] words no I
know some of them oh
oh yeah
yeah I don't see your Dove jokes
those mechanisms okay
I didn't see this one
yeah
it shows me when you get to the club
The Biggest Loser AKA hold on
let me put it on here
you're so obsessed he was in Paris too
large bro I'm cut those schultzy so that
was fun if you don't turn off this guy I
don't know where everything's falling
apart
you got me so excited let me see me real
quick I'm about to play you look at you
mark let me just look at the phone you
know you could just airPlay from your
phone he don't know how to use no the
whole everything to help this
[__] make a goddamn Instagram I
know everything's going bad everything's
going bad
son we've been telling you you think
you're young you're not I'm the first
person to tell you I'm old I've been
married since I was 23 bro I'm [__]
washed all right here we go ready
Mark we've been ready and then we're
going to show you some pictures of you
yeah okay can we oh yeah
[Music]
hold on
[Applause]
like it's a birthday bro congratulations
it's graduation
this is crazy
I represent New York perfect no come on
that's New York
you mad at me videotaping while he
videotape it yeah
I've been Gonna Save the cool way bro
nah all right wow you want to play this
game Mark we can play this oh what are
you gonna do when you slide
[Laughter]
are you gonna get it up this episode
dominating the [__] screen
I got technology on myself this is why
we added the extra episode every week
yeah okay get it up dude I don't know if
it's gonna load bro I'll be honest
hating bro I might not load dude bro I
think the file might be corrupt
it might be a dictator is this the one I
am like
yeah he had a video of me looking so
cool
it's fun to jump the initial part of the
video is one of my favorite Parts okay
at least I know the [__] lyrics all
right all right I need you I need full
screen
okay the first part of the video is
actually what makes me laugh the most it
feels like this is the coolest part of
Mark's life okay it might be it's it's
the it's the day
it is
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I've done this and this is when you're
ready to go home this is why you go home
early hours I stay up another three
hours bro that's what that's why you
look like that yeah you go home in a
reasonable hour you're not gonna be
doing this because you don't want to be
ugly no this was the interlude this is
in between two of the greatest acts ever
okay too good of a party there's too
good of a party bro can you go back to
look like it happened so much yeah you
look like this is the interlude bro I
just don't get too excited you know
oh my God this is so funny I'm so proud
I'm so proud yeah it'll rush to be
washed that is hilarious I'm so proud
look at it but keep going on the song
Maybe I say some wild [__] oh Paris was
a movie bro
you just put these two videos next to
each other
oh bro when I slide
this is how I express myself
bro I thought I didn't have it bro
you're like still got him look at this
dude you got it
I was just about to get up and I pulled
my back a little bit and then I felt
like it was best for me to sit here for
a second until I get everything working
pull your back up I pulled my back a
little bit on the private chat
wow oh just come on
just extended Comfort okay listen guys
can we get this back on track guys come
on Wow when I slide I cannot wait to go
out so don't ran down yeah I'm so
excited to go out bro I was dancing when
you came about that time in New Orleans
I was he was the life of the party I was
dancing yes it is he was the only white
dude there they were surprised that he
moved they were like oh and he was just
hyping them up and [__] like that so he
didn't know that he was dancing
that's basically what it is bro oh [__]
you have some level of skill that things
you think only black people but he
didn't but they were just typing a box
so he just like felt comfortable about
it oh God that was a great the power of
a black woman bro you're like you're in
the club and a black girl like starts
getting you going bro best cheerleader